una de las habilidades más útiles que
puedes tener como desarrollador web es
la capacidad de depurar tus propias
páginas web usando las herramientas
disponibles como las herramientas del
desarrollador que facilita el navegador
en la actualidad cada navegador cuenta
con herramientas del desarrollador así
que en teoría deberías aprender cómo
usarlas todas pero también es bueno
saber cuál navegador tiene las
herramientas más poderosas y empezar a
depurar con ese navegador en este
momento es chrome al menos para mí pero
eso podría cambiar en el futuro ok
entonces abramos las herramientas del
desarrollador de chrome existen varias
maneras en los que podemos hacer eso me
gusta descubrir cuál es el atajo del
teclado para mi navegador y el sistema
operativo y usarlo porque es la forma
más rápida así que en mac el atajo es
comando opción y trans aquí tenemos
nuestras herramientas del desarrollador
otra manera de hacerlo es presionando el
botón derecho y luego inspeccionar y eso
abrirá las herramientas del
desarrollador abrirá la consola de html
así que tendrás que presionar sobre lo
que quieres usar
pero también es muy rápido y finalmente
existe la forma larga la cual consiste
en ir al menú ir a más herramientas y
luego ir a herramientas del
desarrollador y eso también abrirá las
herramientas esta es una forma segura
pero es más larga así que en realidad
recomiendo que busques el atajo del
teclado y que lo practiques una y otra
vez hasta que lo recuerdes ok atajo del
teclado para abrir genial entonces
tenemos muchas herramientas aquí abajo
pero hay una que es la que vamos a usar
y esta que les voy a mostrar es la
consola de javascript
esta consola nos muestra todas las
advertencias y errores relacionados con
las solicitudes de http los archivos de
css y de javascript
además muestra cualquier cosa que
desconectamos así que para demostrarlo
usaré console punto log para desplegar
un mensaje
fíjense que está desplegando un montón
de errores de sintaxis como con solís
modify cndh
eso es porque estoy escribiendo despacio
en este entorno de tiempo real que
constantemente evalúa el código nuevo
así que me muestra todos los errores
mientras tecleo eso es algo que debes
considerar cuando estés usando la
consola en khan academy con tus páginas
web puedes ignorar todos estos mensajes
que están aquí hasta que termines de
teclear y ver en realidad cuál es el
error
o tal vez no hay error listo
la consola me saludo muy lindo de su
parte muy bien hay muchísimas cosas que
puedes hacer con las herramientas del
desarrollador de tu navegador
definitivamente debes explorar las pero
esto debería ser suficiente para
ayudarte a hacer una depuración simple
mientras avanzas en este curso